This next question is referred to the rife machine. I assume it says will this machine. I think they're talking about the rife machine help a delay or reduce the progression of Parkinson's disease.
So, again, even with Parkinson's disease, it's not a matter of, oh, I'm just one therapeutic tool away from making, you know, some big difference in that you got to dig into the Parkinson's disease is destruction of this part of the midbrain way deep inside the brain part of the archaeo cortex.
Um, uh, that, that makes dopamine. So you have almost always with Parkinson's disease, you have antibodies to the substantiate digger, the substantiate digger has the name of that deep seated nucleus that's called a nucleus where all these nerves gather in the deep part of the brain that makes dopamine.
So when you have antibodies to that, it breaks that down and you don't make dopamine. That's what really what Parkinson's disease is. So these people are put on aldopa and, um, which is a synthetic dopamine that tends to work help greatly for a period of time.
And then it tends to start to fail and it doesn't work as well. It has to do with the receptors in the brain aren't as responsive to this synthetic dopamine. They have to increase the dosage. It just doesn't tend to work as well anymore.
Now, there are some new drugs on the market that can be beneficial, but there's still none of them are addressing the cause.
So with Parkinson's disease, the first thing we want to do is run antibiotic tests. You absolutely have to do that. The thing that's missed with all autoimmune diseases, the thing that's missed by most doctors is that when you have self antibodies and you're not addressing the triggers that you might have from foods from molds from pesticides, from chemicals.
Because you can have antibodies to those things too, then when you're exposed to foods or exposed to that chemical or exposed to that mold, you'll fire an antibody and immune reaction and you'll destroy any time again you fire an immune reaction, you'll destroy what you have antibodies to that are already circulating in your body.
So if I have antibodies to my substantiate, I already, because I am Parkinson's disease, and I also, let's keep it simple, let's say I do an antibody food test and let's say it's dairy, let's say I have antibodies to casene, which is the protein and dairy.
So, and I eat dairy, well, I'm going to fire this immune response, so it's going to fire up this immune response and I will kill that which I have antibodies against first.
So can I kill dairy? No, it's not a living thing, but it's going to cause an inflammatory response around that and I could end up with a gut pain.
That's why people who have dairy sensitivities, because they have antibodies to casene, can end up with diarrhea, gut pain, or end of where they'll get inflammation elsewhere in the body, they could enjoy pain, they could get all sorts of different things.
But if I have self antibodies, in the case of Parkinson's to the substantiate diagram, I'm going to do more destruction of that and I'm going to have worse Parkinson's symptoms.
Also with dairy and gluten, it even gets worse and more complicated because you have casio morphine receptors in the gut and the brain and gluteo morphine receptors in the gut and the brains.
If you have antibodies to gluten, or the gluten antibodies or casene, you are going to fire inflammatory responses in the brain, independent of the fact that you have antibodies.
Antibodies, this is the statute I got causing greater inflammatory response in the brain and hindrance of neural conductivity.
So that even makes it worse.
So you want to do those tests. So I would not say so somebody called my staff and said, hey, which is person ma'am, I want to know if the right machine is going to be really good for Parkinson's.
It's not as simple as that. We need to dig into this. I would just go buy a right machine for a disease. You need to get into the nuances of what is what is causing more inflammatory process and more progression of that disease.
And with Parkinson's because it has an autoimmune nature, we know already we need to dig into what are some of the autoimmune triggers.
Now, not to tooth the hoard of our autoimmune chronic disease at all of course, but I go into and nausea in detail of that of what I just said on that course.
So if any of that's part who maybe that's what I got courses, I don't know what is it 75 bucks or something like that by that core start study watching some of those videos and learning that piece of
understanding autoimmune diseases. I have a lot of doctors that actually get on those courses and do that. So I think that will be helpful. So I would not say, oh, go buy a right for Parkinson's. We need to do a little bit more in that discovery.
If you really want to reduce the progression of Parkinson's, you're not going to cure it. There's not a cure, but you can reduce the progression and you can reduce the flares.
And reduce the symptoms by finding those triggers, because you're going to when you find those triggers and eliminate those, you're going to reduce the inflammatory process that's going on that will be a big help.
Thank you.